[Music]
all right can you first explain this
Instagram on the plane with all the guys
cuddled up together what the Spoony life
on the road superhero you just you know
you gotta grab it where you can get it
you know there's no shortage of love in
this cast and no need for sleep and that
there's no there's what there is is your
job is space on the plane so yeah you
know if you're doing if you doing 24
hour days and travel in the world you
kind of get it where you can and asleep
that is do and I had a fine really no I
won easily since sound right uh that's
true you're bringing the hammer and
fighting Hulk
how crazy well yeah you know there's a
after Avengers what was it way up to
there three oak went music good me and
those kind of been on the road himself
and out there traveling the universe and
comes across an old friend from work
that brings them together may or may not
respond with the same kind of you know
excitement and passion as a nap ability
why won't you happy to see me I was
wrapped to see you I think he's really
torn at that point how is it adding
someone like Kate Blanchet to this cast
I'm amazing totally brings our game up
just by being in the same room with her
yeah yeah you call that the contact hi
you kind of stand near certain person
you get kind of lifted as much as
happens when I stand next to Ruffalo and
when I stare next to Chris
you